fachleute weltweit beobachten
ungewöhnliche entwicklung im tier und
pflanzenreich die der klimawandel mit
sich bringt ein us-forscher warnt jetzt
davor dass demnächst ratten in menschen
größe die erde beherrschen könnten aber
das ist nicht das hauptproblem schon
ohne diese größe gefährden sie nahe
zukunft die ganze menschheit kriegs
umsatz im future hier gibt es drei mal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's
herzlich willkommen die folgen des
klimawandels sind fatal und bereits
jetzt in deutschland zu spüren heißere
und trockene sommer
starkregen flutkatastrophen und ein
erhöhtes risiko für dürren all das hat
uns in der jüngsten vergangenheit
gezeigt wie tiefgreifend die folgen der
klimakrise sind direkt vor unserer tür
macht sich die erderwärmung bemerkbar
und das hat teils krasse auswirkungen
auf die tierwelt einige tierarten
verschwinden aus unserer region andere
breiten sich aus bereits vor einiger
zeit ist wohl das erste säugetier an den
folgen des klimawandels konkret
ausgestorben doch es gibt auch gewinner
in der tierwelt die gestärkt aus der
klimakrise hervorgehen könnten der
us-forscher niki latvala hat die
auswirkungen der erderwärmung auf die
verschiedenen tierarten genauer
untersucht und gibt jetzt eine
alarmierende warnung heraus so genannte
schädlinge wie beispielsweise ratten
oder kakerlaken könnten dann aufgrund
ihrer enormen anpassungsfähigkeit
profitieren der us wissenschaftler
spricht von zitaten in menschen größe
die dann die welt beherrschen könnten
und schon bevor sie diese größe
erreichen gefährden sie die gesamte
menschheit was es damit auf sich hat
erfahrt ihr jetzt hier bei pixum science
in future das umweltbundesamt uba hat
schon vor einiger zeit davor gewarnt
dass die folgen des klimawandels die
lebensbedingungen von tieren und
pflanzen in vielfältiger art und weise
beeinflusst die rede ist von veränderten
niederschlägen temperaturänderungen und
extremen wetterereignissen so werden
nicht nur die fortpflanzung zyklen und
die nahrungs beziehungen bei einfluss
tiere und pflanzen siedeln sich in neuen
verbreitungsgebieten an und andere neu
eingewanderten arten konkurrieren
plötzlich mit den heimisch so kann das
komplexe zusammenspiel schnell gestört
werden das iba beschreibt das so biotope
und ökosysteme leben von der
wechselbeziehung verschiedener tier und
pflanzenarten schon eine veränderung bei
einzelnen arten und kleine varianten von
wenigen tagen können ein ökosystem aus
dem gleichgewicht bringen und
nahrungsketten schwerwiegend stören die
warnung des welt biodiversitäts rats
zeigt die großen gefahren auf demnach
sind von den sechs millionen arten auf
der welt eine million akut bedroht ein
drittel aller baumarten könnte
ausgelöscht werden so heißt es in einem
neuen report der un besonders schlimm
die lage in den ozean schon jetzt gibt
es in manchen abschnitten des meeres
kaum erleben zu finden ist nur noch
grünlicher schleim doch wir sind auf die
tiere und pflanzen angewiesen das lernt
jedes kind schon in der schule ohne
bienen und insekten keine bestäubung
wälder und wildnis verwandeln sich dann
stück für stück in wüste und
mittlerweile haben wohl alle verstanden
dass die zeit drängt und dass
klimaschutz und artenschutz eng
miteinander verknüpft sind das
artensterben gehört wurde neben der
klimakrise mit zu den größten problemen
unserer zeit im kommenden jahr wollen
die knapp 200 vertragsstaaten der un
konvention für biodiversität ein neues
rahmenabkommen unterschreiben das macht
hoffnung für orang utans kolibris
spitzmaulnashörner und eisbären darin
gefordert werden nicht nur mehr
schutzgebiete sondern auch weniger
subventionen für fossile brennstoffe und
100 milliarden us dollar pro jahr für
arten- und pflanzenschutz eine weitere
dringende forderung möglichst viele
länder sollen mindestens 30 prozent
ihres staatsgebietes unter naturschutz
stellen das ist auch höchste zeit denn
die uhr tickt eine studie aus dem jahr
2009 10 hatte beispielsweise offenbart
dass die erderwärmung manche tierarten
schrumpfen lässt ein us museum hatte
bereits in den 70er jahren damit
begonnen tote zugvögel einzusammeln und
zu vermessen damals war der begriff des
klimawandels vielleicht gerade mal
einigen fachleuten bekannt mittlerweile
sind es 70 tausend tiere von 52
verschiedenen arten die das field museum
in chicago seitdem katalogisiert hat so
wird klar im laufe der vergangenen 40
jahre sind die züge kleiner geworden und
zwar um 2,4 prozent im selben zeitraum
vergrößerten sich gegen die flügel der
tiere und zwar um 1,3 prozent wie das
forschungsteam in seiner studie schreibt
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler sprechen von der
sogenannten berg manchen regel demnach
haben sich in wärmeren regionen vor
allem spezies entwickelt deren
körperform im verhältnis zu ihrem
volumen eine große oberfläche aufweist
in kälteren teilen der erde leben er
tiere die groß und kompakt sind wenn
vögel also kleiner werden und die
spannweite der flügel größer können sie
ihre körper bei hitze besser
herunterkühlen denn mehr wärme kann dann
abgegeben werden auch andere tiere
scheinen wegen der erderwärmung zu
schrumpfen wie andere studien bereits
nahe legten mit dabei unter anderem
salamander und ziegen doch der
klimawandel hat noch weitere
auswirkungen auf zugvögel wie
verschiedene wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler zeigen konnten vor
kurzem hat ein internationales
forschungsteam herausgefunden dass vor
allem zugvögel die bereits heutzutage
lange unterwegs sind in zukunft noch
länger reisen müssen doch es sind nicht
nur verschiedene vogelarten die der
klimawandel das überleben schwer macht
vor fünf jahren 2016 meldete australien
das erste säugetier als opfer des
klimawandels die rede ist von der
kleinen sogenannten bembel kay mosaik
schwanz ratte die nur im äußersten
norden des great barrier reef vorkampf
ihrer heimat eine tief liegende insel
war aufgrund des steigenden
meeresspiegels mehrfach überschwemmt
worden seit einem jahrzehnt war der
ratten ähnliche nager dann nicht mehr in
diesem lebensraum gesichtet worden und
so hatte das australische
umweltministerium die bembel kay mosaik
schwanz hatte offiziell für ausgestorben
erklärt doch es gibt nicht nur solche
verlierer tierarten fachleute des world
wildlife fund haben einen blick in die
vergangenheit geworfen und analysiert
wie sich welche tierarten im laufe der
zeit entwickelt haben dazu der direktor
der organisation nickel hat war das
klima hat sich über viele millionen
jahre sehr verschoben wir können schauen
welche spezies diese klima
verschiebungen überlebt haben mit dabei
unter anderem würmer krokodile und haie
die sich alle dadurch auszeichnen dass
sie wege gefunden haben auch extreme
bedingungen zu überstehen die
forschenden des wwf haben eine art
bewertungs rubrik erstellt mit deren
hilfe sich im er ist inwieweit eine
spezies klimaveränderung überleben kann
entscheidend für solch eine analyse sind
unter anderem die temperatur toleranz
das wasser bedürfnis die
populationsgröße und die ernährung
schlechte karten haben demnach
beispielsweise elefanten die jeden tag
mehr als 150 liter wasser trinken müssen
wie soll das in langen dürre zeiten
möglich sein doch auch die spezies die
als gewinner aus der klimakrise
hervorgehen könnten könnten für probleme
sorgen in der fachsprache ist von der
sogenannten
biodiversität die rede die damit abnimmt
wenn die gewinner gehäuft vorkommen und
die verlierer weniger dazu sagt der us
biologe freddy ganzen was wir sehen
werden ist ein massiver rückgang an
verschiedenen spezies er zeigt das am
beispiel eines vogelhauses heutzutage
könnte solch ein futterhaus 50 einzelne
vögel anlocken die mehr als zehn
verschiedene arten angehören in 50 oder
100 jahren wird sich das gedreht haben
das vogelhäuschen könnte immer noch 50
vögel anziehen aber es könnten nur noch
ein oder zwei arten seien die spezies
die also nach einer klimakrise übrig
bleiben könnten sich dann vermischen und
den befürchtungen von schröder jantzen
zufolge zu neuen und möglicherweise
tödlichen krankheiten führen die rede
ist von sogenannten schädlingen die in
der lage sind sich gut anzupassen und
auch bei extremen bedingungen gut zu
gedeihen zudem fressen sie fast alles
der us-forscher nickel etwa nennt in
diesem zusammenhang beispielsweise
waschbären ratten und kakerlaken solche
taten könnten also ohne weiteres eine
klimakrise überleben ein problem denn
viele schädlinge übertragen krankheiten
und weil die artenvielfalt sind könnten
wir uns langfristig nicht mehr auf den
schutz eines funktionierenden ökosystems
verlassen krankheiten könnten uns
menschen dann also nicht nur häufiger
erreichen sondern sich auch schneller
ausbreiten möglicherweise könnten solche
sogenannten schädlinge dann irgendwann
auch einmal die dominierende spezies auf
der erde werden dazu nickel etwa nie
sehr langfristig gedacht dann wenn
menschen irgendwann von diesem planeten
verschwunden sind könnte die welt von
einer spezies die ratten dominiert
werden in menschen größe wir können aber
an diesem wochenende konkret etwas gegen
den klimawandel tun wählen um den
klimawandel zu stoppen die klicks vom
analyse der wahlprogramme anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren ist es wichtig
und auch wenn der klimawandel nicht das
einzige entscheidungskriterium für die
wahl ist schaut es euch an und
entscheidet also hier klicken unbedingt
bis dann bleibt dran